I say in the book when I when I walked
in that room I I knew 15 of the other 16
Republicans were running for president I
mean I know Marco Rubio I know John
Kasich I knew you know Jeb Bush I had
met him ah the only one I had never met
which was Donald Trump so he's kind of
curious and I say in the book when I
walked in that room I did not like him I
did not like his persona I thought he
was kind of a blowhard I thought his run
for presidency was a publicity stunt
frankly and we spent in about an hour
and 20 minutes with them and I walked
out with stars in my eyes I'm Dave Rubin
and this is the Rubin report quick
reminder to subscribe and make sure that
you get notified of our videos why not
right okay
joining me today is an author economist
and former advisor to President Trump
Steve Moore welcome to the right Dave
thanks for having me I am glad to have
you here we're gonna have to talk
somewhat quick because you're in a major
time crunch here so this is an honor to
be on the show I'm thrilled to have you
here this can be a little quicker than
my average show so I usually do out the
fire I do a little back story usually I
try to find out where people are from
and all sorts of stuff we're gonna do
that next time I sit down with you let's
go right into economics as Wall Street
Journal guy and a longtime economist and
you studied at George Mason and all of
this stuff how would you say your what
would you say your economic principles
are let's just do 101 more economic well
I believe in freedom and free markets I
believe that you know as Thomas
Jefferson said that government which
governs least governs best and you know
get the government for the most part out
of the way of the economy and it'll do
just fine that's not to say we shouldn't
have regulation we should certainly have
smart we want clean air and clean water
and you know safe workplaces we want a
tax system that raises the revenue the
government needs but in a way that is
not confiscatory how are you listening
Elizabeth Warren and you know we'll talk
about her and it doesn't distort the
economy so I've been a flat tax guy for
all my life you know I love idea you
know let's just have a really low rate
everybody pays it you know you make 10
times more money that I do I pay you
know you pay 10 times more tax and not
50 times more attacks and get rid of all
the loopholes in the tax system so I
believe the free enterprise system is
the goose that lays the golden eggs all
right so I'm basically with you on all
of that but let's let's do the flat tax
for a second so I would
basically for something like 15% for
everybody would you do something to help
the people that are at the lowest yes
what so a certain amount of people were
paying up that sounds like an a standard
flat tax plan you said 15% I'd love that
but most plans were about 18% and then
you basically say for a family for
roughly your first say $30,000 you
earned is tax-free and then you know
above that amount you pay a tax so you
know people below the poverty line are
not paying any federal income tax and I
think most people regard that as fair
and equitable and very pro-growth and
we'd love to see it the reason it
doesn't happen is not even because you
know liberals oppose it it's the special
interest groups in Washington do you
think they want a flat tax right now
they did the lobbyists make money buying
and selling favors in the tax code if
you have a flat tax what do they have to
sell no more no more favors if you
really want to drain the swamp go to a
flat tax would you do anything on the
really high side of that so right now is
there something you would do just to
kind of even if it didn't work sort of
economically in your mind just to kind
of throw you know I progressed it's a
bowl get it I get asked that question a
lot you know I don't like that because I
you know you say well why don't we just
have 20% for the really rich and then
then before not 25 why not 30 why not
you know we have tax rates at one point
in this country 91% so I don't like that
idea because I think it perverts the I
love the idea everybody plays pays the
same rate no you know the idea oh we're
just gonna have a surcharge on the Bill
Gates and the warren buffett's of the
world they will pay their tax you know
when they when they earn their money
they will pay it and by the way they're
those are people who employ you know in
some cases hundreds of thousands of
workers they pay tax so I don't I I want
to I want to retain the virtue and
simplicity of one racist right those
guys are also always for raising taxes
and yet they don't voluntarily I'm not
interesting what do you make of that the
mothers are someone called the patriotic
millionaires so something like a hundred
millionaires and billionaires have
signed something saying you know we want
to pay more tax I call them the
hypocritical millionaires because you
know the you know there's nothing to
prevent somebody you know at the bottom
line of your tax form is if you want to
pay more money into the Treasury you
know you can right
and none of them do that so my feeling
is that they are they want other people
to pay more tax but they don't want to
pay more of themselves and then then
they say well but the taxes isn't
voluntary and I'm like wait a minute
you know people voluntarily want to
serve you know people sign up for the
military though those are patriotic
people they care about our country and
they they're willing to give their you
know potentially their whole life for
our country but these quote patriotic
millionaires won't pay more tax
themselves but they want other people to
pay more tax doesn't become one of those
odd things where it's like the CEO of
Walmart or something will publicly say
that he's for $15 minimum wage where he
knows actually it won't ultimately hurt
him but it'll hurt the small businesses
that won't be able to afford it he'll be
able to afford it yeah you know that's
why a lot of the regulations in
Washington that you know liberals want
they are able to team up with the big
companies because the big companies can
absorb the cost of you know requiring
company to pay health care benefits or
education benefits or raise their
minimum wage so it's a way of actually
of strengthening the big guys and
strangling the small guys who are trying
to you know compete with the with the
big guys so you know the small
businesses are the ones who get hurt the
most by those kinds of regulations right
it's interesting that you mentioned in
relation to tax that you sort of you can
even if you threw somebody a bone that
it's never enough kind of which reminds
me of the $15 minimum wage thing where
Rasheeda Talib said well why not $20 and
then it's like well Bernie or Warren or
the rest of they have nothing to really
stand on to say why it should be 15 and
not 20 because once you artificial in
other ways nobody I'm for the highest
wages Americans can possibly get so how
do you how do you ensure that then
without doing too much government well
you don't want the government have the
government first of all one of the
principles you ask me about principle
economics one good principle is you
never want the government setting prices
or setting wages that's supposed to be
done by the free enterprise system those
law of supply and demand and when you
have the government come in and set you
know I'll give you as an aside you're
reliving here in Los Angeles you know in
a lot of cities you have rent control
you know to try to make you know housing
more affordable for poor people look we
want we all want people to have shelter
and a roof over their head but it turns
out you know this is an improved
example the law of unintended
consequences it turns out when you
actually impose right control you
actually reduce the amount of affordable
housing you actually have more people
homeless not last in New York City found
that and yet liberals seem to never you
know understand that message and it's
the same thing you know with what were
you asking me about the well the minute
the minimum wage it's not hinged to
reality sort of so on someone says it
should be 15 well then why not 20 on our
24 so what happens to happen when you
raise the minimum wage is you actually
the people who tend to get hurt the most
are the people with the least skilled
because you've essentially priced them
out of the market iris tell the story
you know I have two teenage sons I love
them to death but I'd never pay him $50
you know they don't have the training
and skills to to you know warrant a $15
an hour wage why not you know especially
for young people let them work for seven
or eight dollars an hour and gain the
skills you know I remember very well by
the way my first job I think most people
listening to this watching the show
remember that do you remember the first
job you ever had
I do they check what was I was a
paperboy taken well care favored boys
working in a small warehouse in
Northbrook Illinois and you know but you
learn a lot with your first job how to
show up on time how to be nice to your
class how to learn some skills then you
learn that you know whether delivering
newspapers or whether you're you know
working in a factory so I don't like
that about you know I like that letting
the wages rise and and that's happened
under Trump by the way we've gotten a
really nice wage gains under Trump
through the free enterprise system and
creating a very light tight labor market
I mean what workers have a lot of
bargaining power right now
so you advise Trump on the tax cuts a
couple years ago talk to me just a
little bit about like what's that like
when you're sitting in a room with this
guy like what are his guiding principles
sort of economically what you've kind of
laid out their policy a capitalist you
have you do you know Trump I've never
met him first so he's a very he's a
really good guy I mean believe it or not
I say half jokingly you know that he's
kind of most politicians are wonderful
people in public and jerks in private
Trump can be a jerk in public but a
wonderful but he is a wonderful person
private I like him a lot he speak he's
interesting he's charming he's attentive
to what you're saying he looks at you
straight in the eye and he wants to know
and he'll he'll come at you if you say
say you know
hill-hill joust with you if he doesn't
agree with your position which you know
he'll have four or five people in the
room and they'll argue and that's what a
good CEO should do not just surround
themselves with yes-man but people who
will argue out the point so when you
guys sat down and he's going I want to
cut taxes yeah this is one of the things
I promise that now help me pull this
thing example so it's this this tells
you a lot about the tax bill but it also
tells you about Donald Trump so I
remember we went into Trump this was
Larry Kudlow now Larry's now the chief
economist and we said hey you know we we
showed him this chart that had you know
the US tax rate on our businesses was
40% and the rest of world was like out
of average about 20% and we said you
know this is a problem for us you know
that is Larry call that it's a 20% head
start for other countries were competing
with because they've got a lower penalty
that they face and as a result of that
companies were leaving the United States
and they were going to Ireland or
they're going to Canada or they're going
to Mexico this was called inversions
where companies were giving up their
American citizenship to move somewhere
else so anyway we said to Trump we think
you should have a 20% rate in your tax
plan and I'll never forget he sat back
and he said no I'm not gonna do that we
said well why he said I want 15% and
what was so interesting about that was
that from that moment until we passed
the bill in descent late December of
2017 he always insisted on 15% always a
meeting with Mitch McConnell or Paul
Ryan or any public declaration 15-15-15
and I'll never forget we're waiting for
the final vote in the Senate because we
needed to get 50 votes in the Senate to
passes we're nervous about whether we
could do this remember around Obamacare
we came up with 49 votes one vote short
so we didn't want to come up with 49
again and so we're very nervous we're
waiting for McConnell to come back from
his come-to-jesus moment you know when
they had their final meeting and the
house I mean the Senate Republican
caucus see if they had 50 votes and I
remember he walks in was right up to the
president he said you know mr. president
I'm so sorry I failed you
I know you wanted that 15% tax rate and
I made a firmer argument I possibly
could and you know I'm just I've failed
you mr. president what can I say you
know I made I couldn't convince my
colleagues I said I couldn't get you
that 15% he said would you take 20% and
I really believe this the really
interesting thing about that story is I
always thank God
Thank You God that Donald Trump didn't
listen to Larry and I understand that of
the deal I think he wanted 20% all along
but you understood if you wanted upper
20% you know that's not your opening bid
right right so he started at 15 and I I
guarantee you I guarantee you if he had
started at 20% like Larry and I had we
would have ended up at about 27 or 28
percent it's because he started 15 the
negotiated position was 20 well we ended
up actually at 21 percent do you think
do you think basically that is his
secret sauce to everything I mean we
could even take this outside of the
world of economics just that that
negotiating like that is basically that
is his greatest skill well you know the
name of his book right the art of the
art of the deal he's a good negotiator
he is you know I've seen him many times
in person and he knows how to negotiate
you know that's what's made him
successful in business and you know look
he's made mistakes as president I'm not
an apologist for Trump I like you know
where we are with the economy but yeah I
think this is one of his assets he's a
very good negotiator so where are we
exactly right now with the Economist
depending on who you listen to
I mean if I had told you three years ago
that you know after say three years of
Trump not quite three but we're good we
would have the lowest unemployment rate
in 50 years the lowest inflation rate in
50 years the lowest interest rates in 50
years and the biggest wage gains in 30
years
that's a pretty darn good economy yeah
that's what we have right now we have
7.1 million surplus jobs in the United
States think about this that's never
happened before in the history of our
country 7.1 million unfilled jobs that's
larger than the entire population of the
state of Indiana that's how many surplus
jobs you know what that means is workers
have bargaining power goes back to were
saying before so you know you don't like
your job working for Jose you can go
down the you know street and work for
Susan she's gonna give you a you know
higher offer we just have a negotiations
between the UAW and GM you the UAW it
looks like you know they've gotten
pretty much what they wanted in these
negotiations why because there aren't
any it's not like UAW can go find other
workers you know there's a shortage of
them so I think it's been a positive
thing for workers let me summarize if
you are an American
and you were looking for a job and you
have some kind of useful skill this is
the best labor market you know in any of
our lifetimes it's really good so well
it can it continue I think it can so you
mentioned regulation before how do you
figure out where the moments are that
you have to use the touch of government
because as you said you are for some
level of regulation so let me put it the
way I like to put it is look we all
believe in not all of us on regulation
that that you know that makes the
economy run and stops cheaters and
things like that I have a lot of
libertarians that will actually show the
other side just by saying the word
regulation my friends who don't even
believe you should have to write or
drive on the right side my point is that
you I believe regulations should be
guardrails right on the road so to keep
you on the road you know not that the
left believes that fell out of the
regulation should be roadblocks to
prevent people from you know we want our
businesses to succeed but we want them
to stay on the straight and narrow too
many times I saw this in the Obama
administration too many times the the
regulations were just meant to bring
these companies to an abrupt stop and I
think that's the difference we want
regulation that makes sense that's cost
effective and that Jeeves its mission
without disrupting our economy in a way
that will destroy jobs can you give me
an example of a regulation that Trump
has cut you know there was the original
wasn't there that idea at one point that
for every new regulation I was gonna
pass he was gonna cut something like 70
regulation she said why every new one
we'd get rid of - and actually so far
every new one would counter of 20 so
he's been a big d regulator so I'm you
give an example of where something like
that that he's cut has actually helped
off of the best example is in the energy
area I mean you know Barack Obama and
his team hated the fossil fuel industry
they hated shale oil and gas they hated
the coal producers so they passed
regulations that were by the way the law
says that regulations should be passed
in a way that where they're achievable
for an industry in other words that they
shouldn't be designed to bankrupt to
take out but in the area of cut coal
they the intention was precisely to just
put the coal producers out of business
and it hurt our own gas it now we've got
situation we were producing more oil and
gas and coal than ever before we're
producing more nuclear power and that's
created you know for the first time in
our yeah again and your in my lifetime
we're actually producing more oil and
gas than we're consuming I mean that's a
pretty that's a pretty cool thing to
think about we're no longer you know
susceptible to Arab oil embargos or you
know the Russian influence you know we
you know we you saw what happened when
they Iranians bombed the oil fields in
Saudi Arabia that was what about three
or four weeks ago if that had happened
before the shale revolution that we have
going on the price of gasoline well what
are you paying California you pay a lot
but now you know what it is it yeah I
haven't liked your car John but on the
East Coast right if you know you pay
maybe three dollars a gallon the place
of gas probably would have gone to about
six dollars a gallon
if it hadn't been for the fact that the
United States is actually now producing
a lot of oil and gas ourselves so do you
think that the the primary role of the
government basically is to make sure
that the economy is running right is
that really the first thing that the
goes to our life and our liberty you
know and the reason we have laws is to
you know to make sure that I don't
violate your rights and you don't
violate my rights and you know I am I I
I'm kind of old-fashioned I believe if
I'm doing something that doesn't you
know interfere with your rights to life
and liberty that you should be able to
do it I don't like laws that are
intended to for example protect myself
me from myself mm-hmm I think adults
should be able to do pretty much I don't
like drugs
I don't like tobacco I don't I've never
I don't smoke I don't do drugs but if
you want to do drugs I think you're
stupid no comment no kinda yeah but you
know I got the government should be
involved in those kind of decisions yeah
what else should we know about Trump as
someone that has spent some time with
him like not even the negotiating part I
mean he gave us a little insight it's
just the human part but it's a little
hard can you figure it out through the
media one of the things that impressed
me the most and when I wrote the book
Trump anomic swith my friend art Laffer
the first few chapters that I recommend
people read are just if they're
interested in you know how Trump
operates is to read those because we
really talk about how
Trump just as a person what's he like
and he's one of the things that first
impressed me when we went we were called
by Corey Lewandowski was running the
campaign back then and we'll go down the
history books for getting Trump through
that Republican nomination
you know Trump called us in a Reich
something like January of 2016 and said
hey you know mr. Trump would like to
meet you and Larry Kudlow at Trump Tower
and so I was curious about what the
Trump movement was just sort of getting
going at that point but I you could
sense something was going on and I
wanted to see what it was all about and
I say in the book when I when I walked
in that room
I I knew 15 of the other 16 Republicans
were running for president I mean I know
Marco Rubio I know John Kasich I knew
you know Jeb Bush I'd met him out the
only one I had never met which was
Donald Trump so he's kind of curious and
I say in the book when I walked in that
room I did not like him I did not like
his persona I thought he was kind of a
blowhard I thought his run for
presidency was a publicity stunt frankly
and we spent about an hour and 20
minutes with them and I walked out with
stars in my eyes he's an incredibly
charming charismatic person and he's
always personally been very good to me
you know he doesn't throw people under
the bus that are you know loyal to him
and I've tried to you know be loyal to
you know to him and he's he's it goes
both ways when I went through the Fed
Reserve nomination and just got
pulverized by you know all these
accusations against me you know I
remember how we call Trump up I've
called the president I say mr. president
you know if this is a problem for you
you know that you know I hate black
people and I hate midgets and I hate
Jews and I hate you know all these
allegations are my I said look if you if
you you know there's a problem I'm happy
to you don't realize that that's the
clip that people are going to put on
yeah that's with you know the kind of
thing they were saying about me yeah in
anyway so the you know I said you know
sir president that's a problem for you I
don't want to embarrass you or he said
he was get back there keep fighting you
know there and one thing I do you know
respect about trauma and their look
Trump has you know I don't a lot of
things he does and says I don't like it
all I wish you would stop tweeting for
example but you know what I went through
was for about three or four weeks I'm
just getting pulverized in the media
finally
my wife said if you stay in this I'm
gonna divorce you know and so I said
okay I can't take this anymore
Trump took has taken a thousand times
you know what I took and day after day
after day after day
and yet he never lets you know it just
wore me down
ya know how do you how do you think he
does that I don't he's like a superhero
or something in the sense you know it's
like he's got a coat of armor or
something that you know protects him
from you know be from these insults and
stuff you know he's always called a
racist and that's the other thing I
found you know I couldn't believe you
know how many you know blacks and
minorities you have working for him and
they loved him and so you know he's not
a perfect person by any means he's got a
lot of faults but I think he's he's a
the one thing u.s. ask me what is drives
him and it really is how do we make
America great again and how do we how do
we make sure that the economy is working
for middle-class blue-collar workers
because those are the people who elected
Trump you know those who are the people
in Erie Pennsylvania and Lansing
Michigan and Josh cash Wisconsin in
Charleston West Virginia who frankly
were pissed off at both parties Democrat
Sam Republican like the Bush years they
didn't like the Obama years and Trump
knows the people who brought them to
this dance do you think there's any risk
in having sort of pure businessman as
the chief exactly it's a breath of fresh
air I think that's the reason he won I
think people were sick of politicians
remember what was his closing argument
in the election do you remember the
campaign well there were a couple things
that one was what do you have to lose
yeah yeah the one the other one was
drain the slaughter yeah and I got to
tell you that really appealed to people
around the country because Washington
this is one of my little pet peeves and
Trump tapped into this Washington is
getting rich but at the expense of the
rest of us you know three of the five
wealthiest counties in the United States
are in or around Washington did you know
that yeah three of the five how did we
do that we I live I believed in watching
for 30 years we don't produce anything
always produces lot laws lawyers
politicians rules regulations and we're
getting rich at the response of the rest
of the country and you know what the
American people finally caught on
you know it's like wait a minute you
know we're sending all our money to
Washington we send them you know four
trillion dollars they send us 900
billion dollars back and they keep the
rest of the money and I think that's
something that I really admire about
Trump he is trying to drain the swamp it
it's boy is that topper to do yeah so
okay so some of the principles you laid
out here strike me as a lot of comments
and stuff and I definitely fall in line
with that when you now hear the ideas of
socialism being thrown around as if this
is the right set of ideas or when you
listen to say Ernie or Elizabeth Warren
and the amount of government involvement
they want to use to create their you
know perfect utopian society are you
shocked that these ideas gained traction
I am yeah I'm not I don't think shock
would be the term I'd use I'm distressed
I mean these you know I was from I'm
lucky enough to have been friends with
Milton Friedman who was maybe you know
the greatest economist of the last 200
years at least since Adam Smith and you
know he was just a wise man and so so
many things and I was on the front page
of the New York Times in a compilation
with him as some of the leaders of the
far right that's how bananas the media's
cool so I'm sympathetic right situation
an amazing guy and he I remember towards
the end of his life you know which was
around the turn of the century he died
and early you know early 2000s he said
to me and it was a kind of in despair he
said Steve what is the most enduring
lesson of the 20th century and you know
I think we both agreed I think most
people agree the enduring lesson of the
20th century is that communism socialism
Nazism maoism Bernie Sanders ISM
whatever you want to call these things
these government controls of the economy
they're a failure yeah free enterprise
system is a success you know that's the
that's what everybody should have
learned over the last 100 years it's how
the United States of America became the
most powerful economically powerful
nation in the world and then he said but
yet the lesson everyone seems to have
learned is we need more socialism it's
like well you know it's so it is
disturbing I mean we have so do you
think that's just lazy thinking I mean
what do you think that is is it is
branding of capitalism yeah are we or
have we grown fat on all of the XS yes
because it's so those things you invade
to great points number one capitalism we
I don't really use the term capitalism
anymore because it's seen as greed and
you know the rich getting richer so I
think we've lost that term I talk about
free enterprise system and you know let
people start businesses let people do
what they want to do let the let the
economy work itself out the other point
you make is I do think we've become fat
and happy and especially the Millennials
who you know you've seen these Paul's
52% of college graduates now think that
socialism is superior to free-market
capitalism I mean you know how stupid is
that to believe that and yet that's not
part of that is the schools we've done a
horrible job of allowing you know the
left to take over our government school
system and now we're paying a high price
for that we're turning out kids who
don't know anything about anything they
add so it's it's a big task we have at
hand but you know that one other thing I
don't even think we should call them
socialist you know it's people like
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders are
authoritarians
they're the a pit you were not you know
you're saying that you have libertarian
tendencies in 92 I don't want the
government to tell me what to do that's
it they do have to govern they want they
want the government to tell you what
kind of straw you can use what kind of
light bulb you can use in your room work
out what you guys set your thermostat
out what kind of car you can ride at
school you can go to school I mean they
want control of everything and when I
talk to young people I mean this is my
plea I'm so glad to do the show because
I know you've got a great audience for
young people watching the show freedom
and liberty are precious commodities you
know most people don't have the freedoms
and liberties that you and I have for
the people watching the show guard those
jealously
I mean people millions of Americans have
given up their lives to safeguard those
freedoms and liberties and now we've got
a whole generation of kids who's willing
to just throw those liberties and
freedoms away
I mean it de-stresses me well one of the
things that I always find so confusing
about it is that the arguments run so
thin so just in the last couple of weeks
AOC was giving a speech and how she
didn't want Mark Zuckerberg to be in
charge of her health care now I
I don't really want Mark Zuckerberg to
be in charge of my health care I don't
know exactly why I'm saying that but
it's like well what she wants is Bernie
to be in charge of your health care and
it's like I don't know who's worse out
of those two you know they'd be in
charge of your health care you yeah
exactly it was Bobby you know this is
the danger I mean think about this the
two industries I talked about summary
speech idea what two industries in
America are most dominated by government
health care and education education yeah
these are the two industries we've
basically turned over to the government
I mean right look our health care system
is 50 percent private future cent
government right I know progressives
don't want school choice either which is
of course insane don't think about this
though so you got the two industries
that are most run by government guess
which two industries have had the
biggest increase in costs over the last
50 years
genius here so wait a minute I ask my
liberal friends why do we have the
government pay such a big role in
education health care you know what they
say to make it more affordable see
they're doing a wonderful job of it
don't they so why not why not let every
kid you know you and I have to start
moving every child in America whether
they're black brown or you know whatever
color whatever income range wherever
they live it that is a disgrace that
we're sending millions of kids to
failing schools why not allow every
single American to have the right that
Barack Obama had when he moved to
Washington DC and moved into public
housing right and the White House what
did he do he didn't send their kids kids
to the public schools he sent them to
elite private school yeah why can't we
let every single American have that same
right and have the schools compete for
kids and you know competition is a
wonderful thing well just I mean
literally just this morning we're gonna
hold this video for a couple days but I
just saw Elizabeth Warren tweet this
morning about how she basically wants to
take out charter schools and it's like
she did yes it yeah oh my god I just
retweeted it this thing I mean it's like
they want to force people that this gets
to the whole idea you and I were just
talking about who can make a better
decision about what schools their kids
should go to Elizabeth Warren or the
parents of those kids who do you think
cares more about those kids you know
what do you think they were to give the
devil is dude here what do you think the
root of what these people think is like
right like so okay we can sit here and
agree that their ideas are bad let's say
but they obviously don't trust in
government they just have a fundamental
trust and I think something else well
look I think there's a
there's a sinister answer to that you
know and then there's the I do think
Feldman's just believe government is
good and all we need is just to spend
more money on the public schools that's
all we've been doing for the last 50
years and they're getting worse not
better you know so my attitude is just
from I don't care what your political
philosophy is if you keep doing
something over and over it doesn't work
you stop right here but the other thing
is let's be honest about this
who runs the government schools the
teachers unions do what is the most
powerful 35 percent of the delegates in
the Democratic convention our teachers
unions members they run the NGO
Democratic Party and that unfortunately
too many Democrats put the interests in
the teachers unions ahead of the kids
who are though we have the schools that
are supposed to be served all right we
literally all know you you got to get to
a joke in LA can I come back yes
absolutely come back and we'll do it
with no we'll do it with no time left
but in five minutes this is gonna be
almost impossible can you give me a sort
of basic breakdown of where we're at
with China I think this is pretty much
the most confusing thing right now
people have no idea what is being ramped
so it's not just confusing this is the
issue of our time okay you know this is
I've called this well congratulations of
giving you five minutes I know it's the
epic battle of our time just as you know
in the from the 1950s through you know
the late 80s you know was this the cold
war with with the Soviet Union now we
have an epic battle but I think this is
the new Cold War I really do and I think
that this is World War 4 you know that
we've got I mean China why did you skip
three their army why did you skip world
well I think you could say the Cold War
was sort of world okay you know but in
any case I mean I'm exaggerating a
little bit but my point I'm making is
China is becoming increasingly a menace
on the world scene they had marched
towards freedom look mal was the single
greatest villain maybe whoever walked on
the planet Earth I mean he killed you
know tens and tens of millions of his
own people and then finally they moved
away from communism which we were
talking about before and they started to
embrace privatization and free
enterprise not fully but they moved in
that direction and he had a boom I mean
one of the great booms ever in history
what happened in China over the last 30
years yeah the problem has been they've
moved more in a stock
mystic direction now and so they're
building up their military their
cheating on trade deals they've never
opened up their markets to us it's we're
in the way I described it to Donald
Trump not that he'd needed any urging on
this because he got this we are an
abusive trade relationship with China
we've all known our markets to them they
have not opened up their markets to us
they're stealing our intellectual
property
we applaud Trump for finally calling
them out on this it's about time where
this is right now the balls in their
court we have a mini deal right now but
look China could you can't trust these
people as far as you could spit I mean
the problem is they also don't keep
their word so it's a tricky situation
but this is this is a battle that's not
going to be resolved in the next three
months or six months or a year or two
it's probably gonna go on for a decade
or two and the big issue is will the
United States or China be the world
economic superpower over the next 25 30
years you know who I'm gonna put my
money on putting it over your ass you
know why cuz we still do have a free
enterprise system
they are command and control they're
they have the you know they have the
Elizabeth Warren type of a so you think
doesn't work so you think ultimately
that sort of thing might work at some
level for some period of time but
ultimately it fails
tell me anytime I would say to my
liberal friends show me any time any
place anywhere where that model has
worked it didn't work for the Soviet
Union it doesn't work for North Korea it
didn't work for who go shoppin Venezuela
it didn't work for Castro I mean it's
never worked anywhere because the genius
of the free enterprise system is a
millions of actors who make decisions
the idea that you can have a few
politicians in a central Politburo that
can make the decisions about an economy
with you know millions of millions of
decisions I mean it's it's ludicrous it
will break down I'm putting my money on
Silicon Valley you know and they've got
their own set of problems though because
of how lefty they've gone but that
that's a whole other topic that we'll
have to discuss next time I think you
proved to me your vantage over China
yeah I always say this in my speeches
our Chinese are smarter than their
Chinese I think you proved to me you're
an economist here because we probably
got the most amount of ideas packed into
the shorter show as a combination seem
as bad as efficiency there you go
you guys can follow Steve at Steve amor
on Twitter and we will have it back for
a full episode soon enough all right
thanks if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell